vegas is getting lit illuminate is
taking over the stage at the strat
theater jillian lopez she got a
behind-the-scenes look
all right we are lighting up las vegas
as you can tell here i'm here at the
strat getting a behind-the-scenes look
of the new show illuminate the talented
cast has traveled the world they've been
finalists on agt and we are so excited
to welcome them here to our city and
joining me today is the creator mural
congratulations on everything thank you
so much it's so exciting so let's jump
right into it what can people expect
when they come to the show
a fun time a really fun time right now
we're looking to have people come in
dance with us celebrate life celebrate
being together again and just
watch their imagination come to life or
light literally it's a lot of illusions
a lot of dancing
comedy
and just people are going to be
disappearing appearing different colors
different scenes you're going to go to
the moulin rouge you're going to go to
prohibition you're going to see a lot of
different
times in history that we we remember
fondly yeah a little bit of everything
and i was actually watching your
audition back from agt and piers morgan
said that that was the best audition
he's ever seen that is a big compliment
coming from him how have you guys
progressed since that time i mean look
at where you are now
it's been amazing we've traveled the
world we've done a lot with
education as well not just performing
we've
we've done tours
we've
had a show in new york having our vegas
show and it's just been a whirlwind
cruise ships just dreams coming true
right and left and i remember seeing
this performance on tv for the first
time and no one had ever done anything
like this before tell me a little bit
about the technology that you developed
sure i have a background in dance and i
have a background in computer science
and so i wanted to find a way to bring
my two loves together and to also make
it so that people in uh in the non-dance
world could appreciate how beautiful
dance and entertainment is so somehow
illuminate made it so that you can
actually enjoy dance technology and
really have a great night um all in one
well not only is this beautiful but it's
fun and i'm hoping that i can join the
cast of yeah
as well right yes well congratulations
on everything if you guys want to come
out to the show they are dark on
tuesdays but every other night 10 p.m
you got to come out for the full
experience congratulations on all of it
thank you i'll send it back to you guys
jc where's your neon jacket i want that
jacket julia bring me that jacket i
gotta have that jacket i know i love i
love the mixture of art and technology
that's so neat i'm so excited for that
all right you can see i illuminate at
the strat theater wednesday through
monday at 10 p.m